challenger appears
*laughs* *claps* meme review
*claps* meme review
Meme review, that's right
Welcome to S..Sweden's favorite show, that's right (Sweden's national anthem)du gamla du fria, meme review, Mamma Mia
Oh my gahd(god). Do we have some great memes this week! I have been saving up.
These are such good memes that I don't even know where to begin. First meme
FBI is watching meme. oh my god, this meme is so funny
These people on Twitter are saying that the FBI is watching them through this webcam. Hi webcam FBI.
Hiiiii!
In case, you don't know what I'm talking about here
But here's an example . Me smiling to the FBI agent moderating me through my laptop camera before I browse for porn.
Okay that one's funny what whatever. This meme garnered a lot of a lot of
me..*difficulty in speaking* major media News infra..how can
How do I not speak at this point? This meme has got a lot of media attention.
Guys I just sneezed in front of my laptop's webcam, and I kid you not the FBI
Agent said bless you, if that isn't goals
I don't know what is. We're just trying to be nice to the FBI man
Me: *opens laptop*. FBI Agent: oh he's finally gonna
do his homework .Me :*opens up Netflix and disappoints yet another person in my life*
I am such a failure ohhh..
That's hilarious.
Even the mail online the Daily Mail posted about this meme. That's how you know it's good. That's how you know its a.. *kiss sound* spicy..
It's a tongue. hah!
Kisses laptop webcam before bed "goodnight mr.. FBI man." a hundred thousand retweets a hundred thousand.
Who retweeted that? Was that you?
Did you retweet that shit? go away go away. I'm not talking to you. I'm talking to the FBI man of course. *laughs*
*continues to laugh uncontrollably* its so funny
For real though those furry website that was Edgar *Laughs*
This meme sort of placed on the paranoia that for some reason anyone would give a shi..
about what's going on in your life when in fact they don't and yes this meme is garbage
This is a garbage meme. We found another one. This is almost as bad at that god-awful
skediddle skidaddle meme all right at least one of them made me laugh .
skadoo skadae ... do u know da wae
*NFL theme*
(past pewds) I'm gonna let this one slide. (present pewds)You know what that never happened
I never laughed at them, and I never ever ever will laugh at an FBI man meme
Disgusting ,despicable, I'm spitting because I am so upset about this meme
I'm giving it a five pastas. That's the lowest ranking we have ever given it
That's. How. Bad. It is .
Now I know that you are pretty upset, and I'm upset too about this how bad of a meme this was so
*Tries to reach 10 minute mark*
ITS ISOPOD HOUR. Do the dance!
*Isopod anime theme song plays*
The robotic Overlord himself. A man with no heart and no soul clearly loves an isopod now
He's joined the community of isopod lovers . Finally the isopod community on YouTube will thrive!
I've been trying to get it active for years. Can we get isopods trending? Can it happen?
How hard can we shield these memes?*laughs* shitty memes?
Next meme *claps*
You so *incomprehensible*
How do I do this mean without swearing? This is gonna be kind of annoying.
You're so *slowly and discreetly so as to not get the video demonitized* f***ing precious when you smile.
ahh. This meme is fantastic it's sort of , why don't we have a look. You so *incomprehensible*
precious when you smile
Hit it
From the back and drive you .. WILD
*laughs* ahh
This meme is sort of parodying  those god-awful tumbler edits that you see everywhere people put it way too much
ahhh. into editing random
pictures of people that they stan. We are not saying fan we're saying stan.
*Female version of Swimming Pools by Kendrick Lamar plays over the paul brother edits*
Where's the gun? I need it
Some would say people are using this meme now ironically that's not the case they do it because they love
you so *incomprehensible* precious when you SMILE. hit it from the back and drive you WILD.
Girl I lose myself in those EYES
Beautiful, beautiful, there's so many beautiful variations of this
You so
Wait a minute sive sive what are you doing? You're supposed to edit for me , not making this
I don't know if sive or brad is editing this one. What are you doing? You're supposed to make memes for me
This is what you do on your spare time making silly memes.
pewds: Just stupid.
*laughs* ah what else do we got?
The you're so precious meme
it's a, it's sort of taken its sprout. I can see a lot of this going in a lot of different ways
Uhhhhhhh
It does require a lot of editing skill to acquire or at least some to make it decent and thus
It would probably only go so far
But nonetheless a nice little meme that we can all laugh at "ha ha that was funny". Gonna rate this meme ahh.
4 and a 5 that's what this one gets
next
meme
Ok guys if you are
Under the age of 18 click away this video now because it's about to get really really scary
Really really spooky, so be careful make sure at least a parental guardian is by your side. We're gonna watch a scary video
Ok, here we go.
Number 15 Burger King foot lettuce
The last thing you'd want in your Burger King burger is someone's foot fungus.
No
the number 15 foot lettuce meme
now this is *mwah* ahhh. Soso...
Stupid, this meme is fantastic it started from top 15's channel
uhh
Making a video of the top 15 mysteries solved by 4Chan and the very first video b-begins like this:
Burger King foot lettuce
The last thing you'd want in your Burger King burger is someone's foot fungus, but as it turns out that might be what you get
Wheeze
"Number" How do does he do that stupid voice
"Number 15"
Nuh.. numb.. number fiftee..
*laughs*
Number 15
Burger King foot lettuce
The last thing you want in your Burger King burger is foot fungus
But as it turns out that might be what you get
Why does he talk like that and why... I have so many questions?
the absurd..
Absurdity...absurbity...absurdity of this clip made for some nice.. some nice memes.
Here, It's done in a silly pitch. "The last thing. You'd want in your burger King burger in someone's foot fungus."
*dolphin noise*
Completely turning the video around, incredible, it used to be so spooky
Burger king foot lettuce
The last thing you'd want in your burger king burger is someone's foot fungus
but as it turns out that might be what you get.
I.. I don't know why it's funny. It's just so dumb.
There's of course that number 9 Big Smoke ordering
"NUMBER 15 BURGER KING FOOT LETTUCE
The last thing you want in your Burger King burger is someone's foot fung..
Okay. All right.
Okay okay. This meme is sort of turning to the petting dog meme but with feet instead
Goosebumps: Foot Lettuce Edition, The Spookiest of Them All.
Normal foot lettuce aha
Burger King foot lettuce- that's our number 15. Everyone knows that.
Gonna rate the Burger King foot lettuce
Uhhhhhh
It gets a five. cuz it's..... okay
How about this, Burger King foot lettuce: We start off on a five baseline. It gets 2 plus points for foot lettuce.
minus 1 point for 15 and plus....
Yeah, I don't know it gets the rating I guess.
Next
meme
no actually we're done.
Oh!
but we have time for
BONUS
MEME
bonus
meme
Bonus! This meme is gonna be the, you know, "I'm something of a scientist myself" meme ooo
Watch!
"you're quite the science whiz."
"you know, i'm something of a scientist myself."
*Laughs*
Taking this beautiful wonderful
Foreshadowing scene in spider-man and turning it into a bootiful
bonus meme when you put water in the freezer and it freezes to ice
Then you bring it out and it melts back to water
You know I'm something of a scientist myself when someone's talking about chemistry
And you remember salt is sodium chloride *inhale*  yes, of course you know I'm something of a scientist myself
When a lego set says 4-7 years, but you finish building it in three days
you know I'm something of a scientist myself when you overhear some normies laughing at a
Ugandan knuckles meme
*scoffs* I'm gonna-- *incomprehensible* when I hear hot girls at my school talking about their sex life
You know I...fist...myself
When you watch Rick and Morty you know, I'm something of a scientist myself
What someone hits you with a well-constructed and thought-out roast that hits too close to home: no u
The something of a scientist meme hooray a bonus meme hooray
it gets uhhhh
Four point seven
*Coughs*
That was it for this week's meme review
*claps*
Now I'm actually gonna go away. Goodbye. This is my final video. I thought it would be something more sentimental perhaps some tears
perhaps milking it by
Reminding you to buy my merch. Link in the the bi *coughs*
Buy my merch for real. I'm gonna be gone. It's been a pleasure. I'm going away for a holiday to two weeks. sayonara. Goodbye
Goodbye, guys
I'll be back
buy my merch
see ya, see ya on the other side
don't be sad, don't be sad, life goes on
Just going on a holiday, alright?
I'm tired of youtube being everything I do in my life
I need to live, damnit
Stop crying stop crying, you pussy
Come on man, come on man
ow
g-goodbye!